So here are all the y values for these corresponding x values. And we can see
that each of these pairs of numbers, where one is just the negative version of
the previous one, all have matching y values, despite their opposite signs in
x. Let's think about why this is. Well, one way we can rewrite y equals x to
the 4th is y equals x squared squared. We can do the same thing for something
like y equals x to the 6th. That can be written as y equals x to the 3rd
squared. And we know that whenever we're squaring something it's going to
involve multiplying that thing by itself. So if what's inside here, like x to
the 3rd. In the case of y plus x to the 6th. Is negative, squaring it is going
to make it positive. That means that any sine g/ differences in x. Are going to
be cancelled out in y. So that helps tell us why, even when we move way over to
the left. Way to the negative side of the graph. On the x axis. The general
behavior of the graph of a polynomial with an even degree. Is going to match
the behavior on the right side, because of that squaring action here. Now, if
we had a more complex polynomial here instead of just y equals x to the 4th.
The y values to these numbers might not line up exactly. They might not be
exactly equal, because of the terms following this. But by the time we move way
far out in x. Either positively or negatively. This overall pattern would
re-emerge and we'll see the same general behavior on either side of the graph.